east
uh
it's stephen uh it's a pleasure to have
you
stephen wu from carnegie mellon
take it away
all right
um thanks costas um
let me let me know if uh my audio
doesn't sound good in the room obviously
there's no no other way i can know
um
but yeah thanks to organizers for having
me at
this workshop even though i can only
join remotely so
i want to talk about some of our recent
work on imitation learning
mostly led by my excellent phd student
goku swami
and also it has been a fun collaboration
with sanjivan
and drew bagnol and so drew is also a
co-advisor of goku so both sanjiban and
drew are
also
working at a local self-driving car
company called uh call aurora
i would say the only bad thing for
working with sanjivan and drew is that
they kind of make me feel bad about my
own time management for example drew is
a cto of this company and
he still managed to have very much deep
thoughts about research but as a junior
faculty myself i
find it myself often lack of time of
deep thinking of research anyway um so
this talk will be about imitation
learning um
oh by the way the slides are mostly
built on my collaborators uh goku and
zander bonds
so uh in order to talk about imitation
learning i think uh we should probably
start with this general area of
reinforcement learnings and
as we see in this workshop there has
been a lot of theoretical advances and
practical breakthroughs in oil i guess
one of the pivotal moments in rl is
captured by this picture where alpha
gold was able to beat a top gold player
and i will highlight maybe two key
elements behind some of these practical
successes in rl but the first one
perhaps at least in the case of alpha
goal is that
it's relatively straightforward to
specify an objective or some kind of
reward function to indicate whether some
player wins or loses a game
the second is that simulation of a goal
the game of goal or even chess is
relatively straightforward and fast so
you can simulate many many plays of
a game
inside computer many times very quickly
so arguably um
you know
uh gold
and chess and games like that are quite
different from many of the real world
reinforcement learning problems like
self-driving cars or household robots
right for example uh for self-driving
car it is pretty difficult for good
drivers to
distill or enunciate a specific cost
functional reward function
that is especially capture some kind of
good driving
um and exploration in real world rl can
be very challenging
in some kind of unstructured real world
environment
but at the same time uh you know in many
of these real world reinforcement
learning problems you would argue that
there's actually lots of useful human
demonstrations right so we have tons and
tons of data about how good human
drivers drive
so
uh the idea of imitation
learning in nutshell is to think about
how to solve similar problems in rl but
leverage this you know rich set of data
of human demonstrations and
interventions
okay so uh very quickly uh
the paper
mostly based this this talk on is a
paper we had uh back in icml
which is trying to think about
how do you
reason about different
paradigms
of methods solving imitation learning
problems so we try to provide
a unifying game theoretic framework
that sort of unify different ways of
solving imitation running problem
and the key technical centerpiece of our
framework is the idea of moment matching
which is also
at the heart of many problems and many
methods in
inverse optimal control or inverse
reinforcement learning
and what's nice about this framework is
that it sort of allows us to think about
a family of reduction based algorithms
by thinking about
dissolving invitation learning as a kind
of game solving so we can actually think
about different types of adversarial
learning techniques which is sort of the
emerging theme of this workshop
and also theoretically it allows allow
us to derive proofable regret bounds and
the algorithms also have pretty nice
practical performances
right
so this is uh our contributions in a
nutshell
so to put our contribution more
concretely let's give a little bit of
notation so i try to avoid using too
much notations in this talk
but
imagine you have some kind of learner
deploying some kind of policy
making decisions in a markov decision
process so some kind of mdp right so you
deploy a policy in an mdp you will
actually generate a trajectory which is
just a sequence of state states and
actions
and what you're concerned about is
usually maximize some kind of a reward
so there's uh usually an unknown reward
function that map stage action you're
taking in that state to some real value
uh typically it's unknown and in
imitation learning is actually
unspecified you may never observe a
reward ever
and also the way you
the
mdp determine how you transition from
state to state is determined by some
kind of transition kernel
um quite often time this is also assumed
to be unknown
um but in many cases in
at least in self-driving car scenario i
believe in companies like aurora they
actually build very powerful simulator
so sometimes you can actually assume
people know how the transition work uh
even during training time
okay so um
similar to typical reinforcement
learning problem you also want to
maximize
your long-term performance which is
really just the sum of the
the program rewards or the cumulative
rewards
so what is imitation learning trying to
solve in a nutshell really
it's about the following
right so you're given the learner is
given demonstrations from expert policy
so you observe how an expert solves some
problem right solve this underlying rl
problem
and you would like to learn from the
data learn from this demonstration some
kind of policy that sort of map stage to
actions
so that your performance gap or the
imitation gap that is the performance
between
uh the expert and the performance of
your learner learner's policy the gap is
small so you want to sort of close the
gap or to regret
as small as possible
good so uh we're not the first one to
think about mutation learning there's a
long history of how people solve
imitation learning um
but
i would like to give you a quick uh
maybe overview of how some of the
methods uh solving uh what are the major
paradigms
are roughly three classes of methods
and i will roughly characterize them
based on uh whether the algorithm
have access to some kind of human
experts during training
and whether that
album the trading algorithm have some
kind of access to the either the
environment or the simulator uh during
training time
okay
so
uh perhaps the easiest way you can think
of solving this problem of imitation
learning uh is you know
a paper back in maybe late 90s early
late late 80s and early 90s
i think this later we coined this album
as
behavioral cloning which is perhaps the
most straightforward thing you can think
of
um which is just you know you collect
demonstration from expert on how they
solve this problem right so in this case
um i'm stealing a picture from
spencer at all uh the one of the authors
you know providing demonstration on how
to drive a car even though the car is
kind of small
so you collect all these data
on how human
is driving this car
and you basically just treat it as a
supervised learning problem right so you
have sort of the state or the features
of the states that sort of uh the data
input data to a classifier and you have
the action taken by the human which is
sort of the label you want to match
right so you basically treat it as a
supervised learning problem
and
you know you want to have some kind of
policy or classifier that drives the
training error or the validation error
to be small something like epsilon
okay
so uh what you get is basically what
what people like to call the behavioral
cloning policy so how well does it work
so so in this case i'm doing a video
from the others as well so this is how a
behavioral cloning policy would work it
actually i think crashes into a wall uh
somewhere in princeton
um okay so
why did this uh policy crash this the
car right so it's actually
not hard to believe why that could
happen
so
one way you can visualize this is you
know that
the learner is actually incurring some
amount of error in the supervised
learning objective
roughly speaking every time that there's
sort of excellent chance that the robot
or the policy might deviate slightly
from the expert trajectory
okay
but as soon as the
behavioral cloning policy does that um
it's sort of freaked out in some sense
right because it put the car in a
situation where they have never seen any
kind of training
and here you basically don't the the car
doesn't know where to go because the
policy actually never seen such a state
before uh and it may actually keep
drifting away so every time set over the
horizon the t steps you have an
excellent chance to incur linear and key
regret and over time if you do the
proper accounting you actually have
quadratically in t the time horizon
in the imitation gap so you actually
accumulate epsilon t-square imitation
gap compared to the expert policy
so this is sort of a well acknowledged
well aware phenomenon in imitation
learning
to summarize it's really
a phenomenon of how the feedback
compounds errors so as soon as you have
a slight distribution shift from the
expert
this error
due to distribution will compound and it
compounds quadratically over time
okay so and obviously people have
thought about how to fix this issue
right so how do you fix this kind of
compounding error
one way people have thought about doing
is well you know maybe you should invite
the expert
to involve in the training process so
you actually
they can provide some kind of
interactive feedback so uh one of the
algorithms of doing that perhaps on the
first album
a classical algorithm called dagger
standing for
data set aggregation is trying to do
that so so i'm gonna
try to show that pictorially
right so what dagger is doing in the
first step is sort of similar to
behavior applying so you try to collect
how human drives a car right so you
collect all of these demonstrations from
human driver
so you have some warm-up data to begin
with and you also train in policy sort
of as a supervised voting problem
so you have some kind of initial policy
but we know just doing that it doesn't
work right it doesn't avoid this
cascading or compounding error
so
what you do later is to basically now
deploy this policy right
in the environment and as soon as you
notice that you actually have some form
of deviation from the expert data
uh you you basically let the human come
in to correct the behavior okay so as
soon as the dva from the expert
trajectory uh the human expert will
intervene and actually you know through
some kind of controller for example
correct the trajectory okay
and this way you allow the
policy to keep collecting data right so
collecting the data of the form that as
soon as the robot deviates how human
intervening correct for it right so this
is how aggregate data work and allow you
to accumulate a new data and keep
training
and you can do that over
many iterations keep letting the human
correct the policy
uh
and after some number of iterations uh
you know the policy or the robot will
uh drive more smoothly uh behaving much
more like a human expert
okay so the here the solution for
solving this cascading or compounding
error is basically interactively create
the expert during training so basically
what dagger is doing is keep rolling out
this learner to solve the problem and
have the expert to have some kind of
hand holding on the on the learner
while doing that you keep aggregating
data and accumulating data to train a
better better policy
so in this way you actually can avoid
this kind of quadratic in time horizon
sort of regret or imitation gap so you
have sort of epsilon t
imitation gap
right so so if i tell you this album i
think one thing you might complain about
about dagger is that well this is all
nice and good
uh but it's too much effort for the
human right so it's too much
effort to have this kind of hand holding
during the entire training process
basically you have some kind of
watchful
expert looking at every every time step
of the road out of the learning
right so it's a lot of effort so
oftentimes there's a third paradigm um
which is the last parent i will cover
uh so stephen can i can ask a question
just to clarify a little bit
so uh so you have this epsilon time
stick can you specify a little bit what
is epsilon what is t i mean like are you
thinking of a model where like what how
are the errors injected and uh
like why like uh you know is this
epsilon t time good or you know you can
hope to do better like so what is the
can you expect a little bit
yeah yeah
so uh
epsilon
unfortunately we'll have some ambiguity
in the talk so i will explain what this
means but later on epsilon will appear
will have a different meaning so here
epsilon is the supervised learning loss
in in this setup so so think about this
as a supervised learning where
you keep rolling out
expert trajectory keep collecting data
from human corrections so you can
accumulate a large data set or over
multiple rollouts and you try to fit the
policy to minimize that supervised
learning data set and you will have
epsilon fitting error okay that's
assuming you don't get perfect fitting
and that that absolutely is that that
simple coming from that supervised
learning loss
and epsilon t is sort of the best you
can do that yeah
you cannot do better than this because
around you have an epsilon chance of
deviating
uh the best you can do is absolutely
yeah so then like uh so how did this
epsilon d squared arise because kind of
like i was thinking that you know like
why can't you couple the trajectory of
the human and the
you know absolute sub optimal policy to
say that our t steps
i can couple them so that they are i
don't know uh
i mean
uh i i guess it's not a
you're not something you're doing
something else this is distance what is
the absolute t squared this is
so this if you have the interactive x
but you won't have epsilon t squared
um so let me go back really quickly yeah
without interaction why is it absolutely
squared yeah so by the way epsilon t
squared is also you know in the worst
case you have to pay for that so uh one
interesting very quickly is that
you know let's say
you only look at the first t over two
times that
and every time that you know every time
in the first half of the horizon
every time that you have epsilon
probability of deviating from export
trajectory okay
and as soon as you do that you pay for
the entire time verizon like you pivot
linear in t with that
so you can avoid maybe you can avoid
some sometimes that but you know an
expectation if you sum it up but every
time you deviate you pay for sort of t
over two so this is the reward that
you're tracking okay got it yeah okay so
you're a compounding reward errors okay
thanks that's right
yeah thanks for the question
any more questions
sorry for the
simulation all right
so so um one issue about this kind of
interactive expert uh so a setting is
that uh involves too much human effort
so sort of a middle ground people have
also thought about is only assuming some
kind of simulator or maybe you actually
have access to the environment so
here you actually get to
take both the expert demonstrations so
these are sort of offline data you have
collected
but you can still keep rolling out your
policy through a simulator so but
without the hand holding of a expert
what you can do at a high level maybe
you can still match the distributions
even though you don't actually have a
human expert
in in during the training
okay so let me do a quick recap so
basically what we talked about
is sort of three paradigms of how you
might think about solving this problem
the first paradigm sort of the example
of behavioral cloning so you only
observe how experts solve the problem so
you only have data collected and that's
it and you know sort of the thing you
can do is do some kind of supervised
learning treat it as a supervised
learning problem but you might suffer
this kind of compounding error
um the other kind is sort of what dagger
was doing is
invite some kind of interactive expert
that you know wrote out the
learner's policy but keep correcting it
over time okay but it's
very
uh you know exhausting in some sense
that
the expert has to exert a lot of effort
and sort of a middle ground
is you don't assume an interactive
expert but you actually assume some kind
of interactive similar so you still have
some access to the environment that keep
allowing to
to roll out your policy okay
right so um
i'm sort of new to imitation learning uh
but
what we wanted to do in this paper is
that well you know there are different
kinds of methods you can think about to
solve the problem assuming different
kind of access
uh so
what we wanted to do is maybe come up
with sort of a
a broad framework uh
in our case using the language of moment
matching to think about how to design
algorithms uh for these different
regimes for these different paradigms
and now hope is that you know we
actually want to derive some kind of
performance bounce that actually
characterize the imitation gap in these
different settings
and hopefully also derive practical
algorithms motivated by some of these
theoretical justifications
okay
so
this is our goal and i'm gonna
use the imitation gap as a way as a
guiding line to derive the underlying
momentum framework
okay so uh what's our goal so to recap
our goal is to train some kind of policy
pie
that try to imitate the expert policy
uh
really well so that um the imitation gap
is small okay so an imitation gap
captured by some kind of performance
accumulated reward function j
all right so this is well and good but
uh one challenge obviously is that you
know
the reward is unknown actually
unspecified most of the times
so
uh
the performance function is also unknown
so what do you do right so we
actually don't actually know the
objective we would like to to maximize
or minimize the gap
so
you know taking inspiration maybe from a
lot of work
in this workshop and also adversarial
learning
is that maybe we don't actually know
what
the performance function look like
uh exactly but we actually may have some
kind of side of information or would we
maybe
know what is
uh a class function that might contain
this objective function this performance
objective function
so taking inspiration from zero-sum game
or mini-max game what you can do is well
instead of thinking hard about what what
j exactly look like we can maybe
simultaneously try to minimize the
mutation gap for an entire class of
functions that the
performance function might belong to
right so
we sort of can turn this into a minimax
objective
okay
so let me give slightly more details but
you know all the intuition is captured
by basically this slide
so
a bit more concretely you can think
about
basically three ways you can write out
or decompose
uh the imputation gap
um most obviously you can basically plug
in
uh
the definition the vanilla definition of
performance or cumulative rewards and
you can write this as
basically some reward function for both
the experts and also the policy you
choose okay so that that's kind of
obvious
but there are also other interesting
ways you can actually rewrite this
difference
so one very powerful two-way
reinforcement learning uh
performance difference lemma
also allow you to
write this difference as a sum over
uh
the so-called advantages function or or
the sum over the difference in the
q value function so uh q value uh
informally just you know is sort of like
a longer term perspective on reward
basically
uh is
the the cumulative rewards you get by
taking some action at some stage and
then following the policy pie from from
then on okay
uh if if you've seen this before you
don't need to see the definition but uh
if you've never seen this before this is
the only intuition you need
okay so so you can actually
use the performance difference level to
actually write it as the difference
uh over
the q value functions under
the policy
uh under the action chosen by by the
expert
and also under the action chosen by your
policy
what's interesting is that the
expectation is taking over only the
expert trajectory
okay we'll revisit this objective again
in a bit
um
there's actually another way to apply
the performance difference that might be
sort of straight yeah go ahead
would you so where did this tau going is
that like is it the typo so you have
like an experiment oh yeah sorry
is the trajectory so if the tile is like
sort of like a sequence of s1a1
s-t-a-t okay
yeah
yeah thanks
so so you can apply your performance
differently uh in a different way
because sort of symmetric so you can
actually take expectation over
trajectory coming out of the
your own learner's policy
and also compare the q value function
um
on these states you know when you are
taking action
given by the expert and also the q value
function when you're taking action given
by the the policy
okay
so um
we'll you know we will see this
objective again but applying the same
integration we had in the last slide
right
the
the challenge we
with you know
bounding these quantities that we don't
actually know what r is we don't know
what the q function is
um but what we can do is that we can
introduce maybe class as a function that
if we know or assume contain these
functions right so you can replace or
upper bounds
this objective by introducing some sort
of maximizer
maximum over some class of the function
that contain
uh either the the reward function or the
value function the q value function
okay
so in particular uh by doing that you
can actually
sort of reformulate a problem nicely
into three different mini max games
um so
meaning back end between two players one
player controlled which policy to deploy
the other player is sort of like the
and again that choose which uh function
f to to penalize
uh the policy player
and what's nice about some of these mini
max game is that if you think about the
game values or the minimax value of
these games it upper bounds the
performance difference
between the learner
and the expert
so so let me
organize this a little bit
so we actually
uh have a naming for for these games and
you know in a second it will be more
intuitive uh the first kind of game is
called the off cue game so it's offline
because you're only collecting experts
data
um
and uh what's
important about this is that in the
objective you're only taking expectation
over the expert trajectory so these are
sort of the data that's already given to
you these are the expert wrote out
trajectories that you have observed and
collected so far
so
importantly in this game you don't
actually need access to any simulator or
expert
okay so that's sort of the off-cue game
because
you're in an offline setting you're only
collecting observational data
and you would like to sort of match
the q value moments
and the second one is sort of the reward
matching game uh so so here uh you sort
of
requiring in addition to expectation
over
um
the expert trajectory you also have
expectation over a learner's learner's
trajectory so you actually require some
kind of interactive simulator and you
also need to match uh moments that
behave like reward functions um yes
facilities
oh sir yes i didn't want it everybody
like since you stopped uh so
the previous qualities hold it for the q
function
uh is it clear like so if i do the soup
over there it's clear that the solution
to this
will achieve a small error with respect
to the original objective because now
you you know maybe there's some terrible
f in there
like is it is there a policy that will
make this zero for all f yeah they may
not i think um yeah you're asking a
more in-depth question i think the short
answer is if you have near realizability
or realizability yes
uh
without realizability it's challenging
yes
so suppose that there is a reliability
mean that the true q function lies in fq
so and if the policy class pi include pi
e then you you can always just play pi
like a minimized strategy could just be
pi e that is always zero
yeah
that's you yeah okay but that doesn't
mean true and there's an issue
that i don't think
yeah this paper address
clearly
yeah thanks
so um
but lastly there's a third type of game
which is uh we call it on cue game which
is
uh
sort of the most demanding in terms of
access to both requiring a simulator and
also an expert so if you look at the
objective it's sort of obvious in the
sense that it required taking
expectation
over
the learner's learner's trajectory so
you require rolling out pulling out the
learners of policy but also you also
need to query the experts
along the way of you know the states
listed by visited by the learner
so you require both interactive and
similar uh and directly expert and
simulator and here you also try to match
uh some kind of key value moments
okay
um
so what's nice about some of these uh
minimax formulation is that uh
it's sort of capture or recover some of
the special cases uh some of the
previous albums and the special cases
are well aligned with some of these
other algorithms so for example in off
cube game where we're trying to minimize
divergence between the learners
and experts actions on the stage visit
by visited by the expert trajectories
this is sort of reminiscent of
algorithms like behavioral cloning and
value dies
in the on-cue game where you're
minimizing the divergence between
learner and expert actions but now on
the stage
along along the along side of the
learner's trajectories uh it's sort of
mimic
ideas like a dagger and other algorithms
and the reward matching game i think
you minimize just the divergence between
both
the entire trajectories by learner and
expert
uh so that's
uh
sort of aligned with uh with some of
these algorithms like miguel at school
okay
so um
and what's nice about uh
the game
theoretic framework is that also give
you a whole family a way to solve
this kind of uh problem by treating it
as an equilibrium computation problem
right
so one one thing you you could show is
that
you know if you have a approximate
equilibrium in these moment managing
game you also should be able to solve
the underlying multiplication learning
problem
uh so
very quickly uh we'll
we'll think about the concept of
basically epsilon epsilon approximate
equilibrium okay so um
roughly speaking is just like a pair of
strategies one given by the policy some
policy one given by some discriminator f
uh so that
no matter which player decide to deviate
and take on another strategy whether
it's a policy or a discriminator uh that
any player can now
gain by more than epsilon okay
so um
so one thing we can show is sort of a
way to translate a guarantee from
computing a
approximate equilibrium of the game
to
a performance or imitation gap in in the
imitation learning problem okay so for
this um
uh
it's a bit unclear to me like your
family f does it depend on the expert
policy
uh
in some cases yes uh so in the reward
and uh off um
it's the
[Music]
on cues i think it does yes
so
i guess maybe a better way to answer is
i only need to assume that the expert
policies value functions belong to the
class of f
which i'll get to into both points but
does that answer your question
uh
kind of so i guess my question is like
you know the expert policy is supposedly
something that does well with respect to
true reward right
so
so is that sort of reflecting in the
class
f
yes
yes as in you know the f should contain
the value functions by the expert policy
in one of the in one of the cases
but also it should not include things
that the expert policy is terrible right
uh i don't think i think it's related to
what uh brazil is asking yeah i guess
like uh if if the expert is terrible in
some like some terrible reward function
uh i should be matching that terrible
terrible value so in some sense it
doesn't matter
does that answer your question there
not sure below okay no yeah maybe
following up yeah maybe following up on
that like so what if my
my function class f contains the value
function of some terrible policy not the
expert policy yeah
then in some sense i'm also trying to
imitate that terrible policy so
what's up it's not positive so maybe
maybe a quick clarification question f
is not capturing policy but capturing
something like rewards or a valid value
moment
yeah but it's like the value at uh under
the expert policy right it's trying to
capture that
like the they say the q function under
the expert policy or the value function
under the expert policy so maybe it's
easier to think about we work first
like value is a little tricky to think
about but for reward right like you know
i could i could do terrible the expert
policy the real x policy can do terrible
according to some reward
um
and
you know i should be
you know matching that moment under the
expert policy
um
so in some sense i should not deviate
from that expectation
so stephen i guess what you're saying is
if the
expert policy performs poorly on some
reward you are still asking your pie to
match that on that terrible reward
yeah but you don't have to right
you can say these are terrible these
rewards are not going to show up because
the expert is actually should be doing
well so let's forget about those in my
class
i guess it's a stronger guarantee like i
think
it implies that you know on the actual
reward you also do well yeah like
solving a minimax publish is like
strictly harder than directly giving you
a reward from chance
so i guess like like uh if the policy
class contains at least the expert
policy
and if i make no further assumptions
the best epsilon i can hope for is
something like root t
as in whatever i'll get from some
martingale argument
that like
if i let's say like
even without sampling errors right
like i the word one of them would be
coming on sampling error
right
i mean
i see yeah
let's not
yeah let's not think about that okay
maybe that's like distracting yeah but
you know if you if you can perfect
evaluation of expectation
realizability an infinite sample should
buy you absolutely zero
okay i'm happy to uh to discuss more but
i want to keep going because i think
it's running a bit
like
actually i'm way
behind um
actually do i have until the
hour the end of the hour
yeah that was the original plan but uh
you can get another five minutes
okay all right let me maybe i have to uh
skip some of those steps um
but one nice thing about uh
this equilibrium structure is that you
can actually translate the approximate
equilibrium guarantee into um some of
the guarantee on the imitation gaps um
and
you know in the off cue setting you you
actually expect sort of a quadratic
error um in the on cue setting i think
it's a little more subtle
the balance a bit more neurons in the
sense that it depends on
also another parameter that's on the
the class of functions uh which we call
it h recoverable it's a little
mouthful to state the definition here
but roughly speaking um
it sort of requires the expert
to take the expert edge steps to recover
from any mistake so if you
sort of capture the idea that if you
know the learner policy dva from
from the expert trajectory by following
the experts uh policy you can actually
recover uh in extents okay
and um
we can actually prove some of these uh
matching lower bounds
at least on the dependence on epsilon nt
okay
um
so
this is a formulation of minimax games
and uh i think many people in the room
know how to solve minimax game quite
well
uh and
one of my favorite ways to do this is
sort of
perform some kind of no regret dynamics
that sort of uh
you know perform some kind of repeating
plays over any iterations um
and you know the policy player will
basically iterately update some
underlying policy and the discriminator
will iterately pay some kind of moment
functions to penalize the policy player
so
um
you know suppose they both are trying to
minimize some sort of accumulated regret
um
you know given by sort of you know the
the cumulative reward of costs they
achieve over some iteration
you know compared to the best
uh benchmark in hindsight
one
well established results in minimax
and games and also online learning is to
show that you know if the regret is
uh growing something you're in a
number of steps you also are able to
compute
approximate equilibrium of the game
um so
uh
this will sort of allow us to think
about
different recipes of designing
algorithms under this kind of no regret
versus uh
best response kind of out with them so
you can actually have some freedom to
choose whether you decide to
implement some kind of no regret
algorithm on the policy player
or
uh have the no regret out of them play
on the
uh the discriminatory player and let the
other player best respond to everyone
okay so um i think this workshop i've
seen a lot of these kind of algorithms
and
so one one quick result we can prove uh
sort of a theoretical result um
is
you can actually
provide some kind of reduction to this
kind of no regret oracle or best
response oracle and so basically kind of
minimax scan all three kinds of minimax
games under uh polynomial iterations
um
you have to do a slight bit word from
the standard framework but i think the
proof is not too surprising from you
know for those who are used to thinking
about solving games using no regret
algorithms i think what's more
interesting about this result is that
it allows you to
think about uh some kind of paradigm to
design practical outcomes so arguably in
practice you probably don't want to
implement provable no regret algorithms
like uh follow the perturbed leader
so you can think about uh some some sort
of neural network or gradient based
optimization
uh
so you can actually do that you know by
reconfiguring some of the subroutine by
replacing some of the more powerful
solvers in reinforcement learning uh so
for these three different games uh i
think we were able to come up with three
different algorithms they kind of have
funny names because
my student goku like to be creative in
coming up with names they call advil
agile and daniqua
i think it takes a little while to
understand why they call that in fact as
the advisor i was a little worried about
student because
it looks like the student has spent too
much time in the pharmacy uh but
the algorithms work pretty well
practically i take on
three different tasks i think
they
under different assumptions of whether
you have access to environment or the
expert
they tend to outperform some of the
standard benchmarks
okay so
i'm about to run out of time
i want to
quickly wrap up a little bit uh so to
summarize for this paper um
i think
uh what's nice about this is it's kind
of like a nice game theoretical
framework to think about all these three
paradigms of uh how to solve mutation
learning
um
and you can derive a different kind of
uh imitation gap and what i didn't touch
on is you also have a different kind of
uh sort of computational requirement for
how to solve your underlying game
notably the reward uh matching
type of algorithm
uh the most natural algorithm we are
aware of so far tend to involve solving
some kind of planning problem so
basically when the discriminator gives
you some kind of adversary reward you
have to solve some kind of planning
problem uh over the mtp defined by this
reward function
uh what i didn't have time to touch on
actually my
our paper didn't fully resolve is you
know related to cause this question
where does this epsilon come from right
i think so the epsilon in the definition
of our paper sort of correspond to the
approximate equilibrium uh parameter
right so sort of the moment matching
error defined by the minimax scheme
uh but we didn't really account for
where it comes from which could
come from roughly three sources could
come from statistical error like how do
you estimate the expectation of these
moments
and it could be coming from some sort of
error like non-realizability uh like
approximation due to limited function
function class
and it could come from maybe like uh you
know approximate optimization
of your solver potentially so so
all these questions we're studying i
think we
slowly making uh some of the progress
along these lines uh for example in a
recent collaboration between
our team and a
group of researchers that berkeley uh i
think the lead co-authors the student
co-authors matthew pong goku swami and
yvette
we start understanding you know in some
of you setting what exactly are the
statistical complexity what's the
optimal sample complexity when you start
making
some of these assumptions such as
realizability or deterministic expert to
isolate the statistical uh complexity of
the problem
and maybe one nice takeaway is that
you can think about some sort of more
interesting algorithm that doesn't
directly just apply moment matching but
some sort of hybrid hybrid i would
combine some of the idea from behavioral
cloning and moment matching
i think i'm sort of valid time but uh
you know
goku also has been making progress in
thinking through some of these
imitation learning problems under
unobservable compounds
one nice result uh
we had is uh thinking about how to
combine the idea
of adversarial learning and instrumental
variable uh regression in in the
imitation learning center uh so there's
actually a nice also sort of game
theoretic type algorithm for for solving
this kind of uh imitation learning
problem under unobservable compounds
but i guess i will skip this i'm happy
to discuss offline
so
in summary um
i think i'll work sort of make a nice
case study with
related to the theme of the workshop
which is you know thinking about
adversarial learning and mobile matching
can be a nice recipe for deriving and
mutation learning methods
and um
there's still a lot of understanding we
need to do uh
to
figure out the computational statistical
trade-offs on the different
imitation learning paradigms and
assumptions
uh which our work doesn't fully address
yet
and
i think interesting over direction that
we are very excited about is whether you
can apply this kind of adversary
learning techniques or game solving
techniques from the minimax perspective
to solve some of the harder imitation
learning problems
for example maybe there's unobservable
confounders in the in the expert
demonstrations
or maybe the experts are not necessarily
perfect or or have some kind of defects
okay with that i would like to conclude
my talk and thank you for the questions
any questions
[Music]
for stephen
you know
yeah hi stephen so i think it's really
interesting to see that all these three
paradigms of imitation learning can be
all framed into me max
uh optimization as
i was wondering like uh also kind of
coming back to the the the question by
lastness is like so
of course the way how you choose this uh
function class f right for the test
function or discriminator
affect the optimization azure affects
the statistics side but i was wondering
in your results you've shown that this
compounding error has nothing to do with
kind of how you choose the function
class but only depends on realizability
is that's the case
uh for the compounds the result which i
guess i didn't talk through much uh
no i mean the the compounding error that
part compounding here yeah yeah where
there it doesn't really depend on
whether like how large is the function
class but rather just on the
realizability assumption right
um
that's a good question so
i think even under
realizability assumption
uh i think the compounding error in the
purely offline setting is unavoidable
uh
because
uh even if you know your policy contain
the expert's policy
even if the the class of functions the
discriminant class function contain the
true
uh value function
uh
you know there's still a chance of this
kind of epsilon error equivalent over
time because of finite sample because of
the finite example you only see
in the expert data
so
anyway if
as
as long as you're not solving this
underlying supervised learning problem
or the moment matching problem perfectly
that error will compound quadratically
over time
so that i think that's still going to
happen
uh even if you make realizability issue
i think you can avoid that if you have
both realizability assumption and also
infinite sample
assumption then you can avoid the
uh you can avoid a compounding mirror
yeah so this is why uh behavioral
calling could work i don't have a second
question is like i think in general like
this reward matching or this inverse rl
where you try to learn the reward it is
also known that it's kind of your post
and oftentimes you need to add some
regularization right so for instance max
and jpe etc like here like do you see
any like a need to add like some
regularization either on the function
class or on the policy side to improve
the performance yeah i think implicitly
i think actually explicitly some of the
algorithms actually do that i think
especially in this last work we
mentioned we actually have
regularization on the discriminatory
class and
uh i think
you know some of the
you know experiments definitely rely on
you know maybe not explicit
regularization but you know like slow
learning rate um yeah so definitely i
think that plays an important role
at least in the practical performance i
think that's a very good point
oh yeah thanks a lot thank you for a
question
so i had a question about the i think
that series also has one so i had a
question about your uh
the no regret learning you mentioned
like uh
so
uh are you returning
distributions over policies and
distributions of rfs and you're playing
a mixture of our policies i mean your
problem isn't convex or is it i mean it
didn't look like it's
very good
um
so
i knew someone was going to ask this
probably proper game theorists will ask
this uh but
uh first of all i think uh there are
depends on how you view the policy so
the one one one nice way to view this
kind of problem is to think about in the
space of
occupancy measure like if you have a
policy it can correspond to
a
state action
distribution a distribution over state
action pairs so you can think about that
representation if you think about that
representation of the policy and
everything is linear so basically like
you're actually assigning value to every
state action everything is linear
um so in some sense the
the nicety and minimax theorem still
holds
but your question is you know uh you
probably should be if you're playing
over all then we probably would be
playing mixed strategy
uh
which will mean make its policy so
theoretically i i don't think it matters
i think there's a well-known result by
uma
mike michael
of course last name and watch a period
that basically tell you if you can take
the
mixed strategy
write down the occupancy measure which
is distribution over state and actions
you can rederive a single policy that
matches with the
uh
the
you know state action occupancy measure
so you can always you know without loss
to assume that you have the same a
single part singleton pause
at least theoretically
in practice we don't actually run
like multiple ways
so practice you degraded descent um
yeah my question my question was more
like uh on the practical so like uh you
know
like for example like uh is gokul or
andre applying these types of algorithms
in
like self-driving cars and if so like
how do you choose an f there like what
are what are the types of apps that
people function classes that people
choose
are they yeah
and how are they informed by domain
experts or something yeah yeah i think
it's a challenging question so i think
the honest question i answer is i don't
know i can tell you what we did in
experiments which
i'm mostly given by two layer neural
network
um and maybe some form of rkhs
uh yeah but i installed driving car
domain i i don't i don't know i think
you have to incorporate some other side
information like you know hopefully
the app should incorporate ideas like
you should not crash into the car in
front of you
that should
like aspect like you know good driving
that should be captured into this kind
of function class
this is okay
yeah
but then if you know if you're
so that's you know so you're very you're
allowing it to be very powerful in terms
it's a non-model like if you if you're
if you're you're if you're in the
unrealizable case and say under the true
q function or value function you have an
epsilon
uh
error uh by moving to the super verif
that could be blowing up because maybe
there's something
that would be a maybe a drawback in
thinking about super expressive
function class i do think that's an
interesting trade-off that
maybe it's related to all the questions
you had again
uh that we did not address well
like because the game value will be also
large in that case like it might not be
close to zero exactly yeah yeah
yeah i think that if you allow for for
unnatural test functions then yeah you
could have like a huge
game value
in the unrealizable case
yeah
i think that's an interesting trade-off
in for iowa
all right so
i think uh i think we reached our
capacity
for the day
uh thank you very much uh stephen for
keeping our interest very active uh even
at this uh
advanced time and also like uh thank you
for staying up uh you know like uh
postponing your dinner plans and this
ghost
talking to us thank you very much thank
you
[Applause]
you